la estructura de louis para el c2 h4 se
muestra abajo en el recuadro de la
izquierda en el recuadro de la derecha
dibuja todos los pares de electrones
para completar la estructura de louis
para el c2 h 5 o h o etanol ok como nos
han dicho aquí tenemos la estructura de
louis del eterno y nos piden que
dibujemos todos los pares de electrones
para el etanol bueno lo voy a hacer de
una manera en la que podamos ver qué
electrones vienen de qué átomo aunque
eso no nos lo están pidiendo pero miren
voy a poner en azul los electrones de
los hidrógenos entonces cada hidrógeno
contribuye con un electrón para formar
un enlace covalente podemos decir que
este hidrógeno contribuye con este
electrón este hidrógeno contribuye con
este electrón este hidrógeno contribuye
con este electrón este hidrógeno
contribuye con este electro
este hidrógeno contribuye con este
electrón y este hidrógeno contribuye con
este electrón ok ahora vamos con los
carbonos si presentan un examen como
éste probablemente no tengan muchos
colores a la mano pero yo lo haré con
diferentes colores para que puedan verlo
entonces vamos a ver cada carbono tiene
4 electrones de valencia que contribuyen
a la formación de enlaces covalentes
entonces este carbono tiene 1 2 3 y 4 y
este carbono contribuye con 1 2 3 y 4 ok
y ahora vamos con el oxígeno bueno el
oxígeno es muy interesante porque miren
tiene dos pares de electrones libres
entonces tiene un par de electrones
libres por aquí y un par de electrones
libres por acá y después como está
formando un enlace contribuye con un
electrón en este par
y con un electrón en este par entonces
cada par de electrones que tenemos aquí
representa un enlace covalente ok ya
dibujamos todos los pares de electrones
ahora vamos con el inciso el cual es el
valor aproximado del ángulo de enlace
carbono oxígeno hidrógeno en la molécula
de etanol bueno nos están pidiendo el
ángulo de enlace de la molécula de
etanol
vamos a ver tenemos el oxígeno que está
unido a un hidrógeno y también está
unido a un c2 h 5 c 2 h 5 y nos piden el
valor aproximado de este ángulo de
enlace bueno es importante darnos cuenta
de que cuando se forman estos enlaces
con el oxígeno la geometría de la
molécula es muy parecida a un tetraedro
porque bueno porque el oxígeno tiene
estos dos pares de electrones libres
entonces estos
dos pares de electrones libres están
formando las otras partes o mejor dicho
los otros puntos de la figura te trae
drica y por ejemplo si estuviéramos
hablando de una molécula de agua si
hablamos de una molécula de agua vamos a
dibujar un par de electrones por aquí y
el otro par de electrones libres está
por acá
mejor voy a dibujarlo así entonces si
hablamos del agua voy a dibujar un
hidrógeno hacia nosotros y por acá
tenemos otro hidrógeno lejos de nosotros
y después tenemos un par de electrones
por aquí y el otro par de electrones por
acá miren este ángulo de enlace en la
molécula de agua bueno yo creo que es
importante que sepan esto a simple vista
parece que son un poco más de 100 grados
y de hecho si este ángulo esté
aproximadamente ciento 4.5 grados pero
no es una geometría te trae drica
perfecta está un poco distorsionada
porque estos pares de electrones libres
se repelen entre sí provocando que estos
dos se acerquen un poco más pero cuando
tenemos una geometría tetra hedrick a
perfecta tenemos algo hacia nosotros
algo lejos de nosotros y tenemos dos
cosas más que están así esta es una
forma de ver una geometría te trae drica
y miren el ángulo de enlace entre todos
estos podemos decir el ángulo de un
tetraedro que no está distorsionado es
de ciento 9.5 grados y ese es un valor
razonable para esta pregunta déjenme
conectar el tetraedro aquí tenemos un
lado y por acá quedaría el otro no sé si
eso les sirvan mejor dibujaré otro
aquí tenemos un tetraedro y es
transparente entonces tenemos una
molécula o un átomo en el centro y
después tenemos cuatro enlaces 1 2 3 4
bueno pueden ser cuatro enlaces o pares
de electrones libres y volveré a dibujar
el centro ok y aquí el ángulo es de
aproximadamente ciento 9.5 grados así
que esto también tiene una geometría te
trae drica porque tenemos estos dos
pares de electrones libres que se
repelen un poco entre sí entonces esto
se parece mucho a lo que sucede con el
agua y con un tetraedro perfecto
entonces podemos decir que el ángulo de
enlace se encuentra entre 104 y 110
grados entre 104 y 110 grados de hecho
podemos decir que es mayor a 104.5 pero
bueno no lo haré más complicado sólo nos
están pidiendo
que digamos cuál es el valor aproximado
así que podemos decir que cualquier
valor en este rango es una buena
respuesta